israel es uno de los países más
controvertidos del mundo y lo cierto es
que resulta muy difícil hablar de sin
referirnos a guerras religión o
conflictos políticos varios sin embargo
con este vídeo en visual político
queremos verterlo sobre otra cara de
este país porque amigos en las últimas
décadas israel se ha convertido en una
de las mayores potencias tecnológicas
del mundo y esto es algo que resulta
sorprendente
de un país pequeño que con apenas 8
millones de habitantes una población
inferior a la de andalucía y una
superficie equiparable a la de la
comunidad valenciana en españa o el
salvador en latinoamérica cuenta atentos
con más de 4.000 compañías tecnológicas
y 80 de las 500 mayores empresas del
mundo tienen aquí filiales orientadas a
la investigación y la innovación
de hecho tel aviv extras silicon valley
el polo de tecnología e innovación más
importante del mundo y aunque parezca
mentira por su reducido tamaño israel es
el tercer país solo tras eeuu y china
con más empresas cotizando en el nasdaq
la bolsa de valores de eeuu orientada
preferentemente a compañías tecnológicas
hablamos de que israel tiene más
empresas cotizando en este mercado que
la suma de españa italia francia
alemania y holanda casi nada pero
queréis ejemplos concretos pues bien en
israel se está desarrollando gran parte
del hardware del próximo iphone 8 muchas
de las características de google son
made in israel e intel el líder mundial
de microchips le debe gran parte de su
éxito a las innovaciones de su filial
hebrea la cual por cierto con más de 11
mil trabajadores es una de las mayores
empresas de todo el país bueno e incluso
microsoft ha llegado a considerarse como
una empresa en israel
technologies paypal ibm cisco amazon
facebook son muchas las empresas que
utilizamos cada día cuya tecnología
depende en gran medida de este país
volcado con la i + d + i y es que este
sector supone ya ojo más del 12 por
ciento del pib el nacional más que el
turismo en españa por ejemplo y la mitad
de todas las exportaciones y os
preguntaréis cómo ha conseguido israel
semejante éxito porque este es el punto
más importante habitualmente se alude a
factores culturales
pero hoy queremos prestar atención a
tres políticas claves en todo este
proceso
yo
en israel la década de los 80 se
recuerda como una década horrible
especialmente desde el punto de vista
económico por aquel entonces el país
atravesaba una dura crisis la inflación
entre 1980 y 1985 superó el cien por
cien cada año los déficits públicos y la
deuda eran prácticamente inasumibles y
la economía en general estaba maniatada
por una excesiva intervención del estado
en buena medida a que el israel era muy
dependiente de la ayuda llegada desde
diferentes partes del mundo y aunque la
situación comenzó a estabilizarse a
finales de los 80 justo en ese momento
comenzó la masiva llegada de población
judía procedente de los diferentes
territorios de la unión soviética en
poco tiempo llegarían al país 800 mil
personas ojo con la magnitud porque fue
algo así como si en apenas una década
llegaran a españa 9 millones de
inmigrantes y en este contexto la
pregunta era clara cómo generar empleos
para tantas personas con una economía
deprimida sin duda a israel le tocaba
cambiar nos curamos
como equipo o nos desmoronamos en un
primer momento el gobierno apostó por
explotar la cualificación de los recién
llegados promoviendo la creación de
empresas con subsidios e incubadoras que
apoyasen la labor de los emprendedores
pero pronto se dieron cuenta de que este
sistema aunque conseguía desarrollar
ideas apenas lograba crear empresas
prósperas con los inmigrantes no tenían
experiencia en la gestión carecían de
redes comerciales y apenas conseguían
financiación al fin y al cabo quien iba
invertir su dinero en un lugar tan
convulso como israel y aquí fue donde el
gobierno de israel se dio cuenta de que
la clave estaba en apostar por atraer el
capital riesgo internacional es decir
atraer a aquellos fondos orientados a
financiar nuevas ideas y nuevas empresas
desde ustedes cuenta que aquellas
sociedades más avanzadas aquellos puede
ser más avanzados tiene unos capítulos
muy bien muy fuertes para lograrlo
crearon el ingenioso y exitoso programa
dogma con él el gobierno creó 10 fondos
de capital-riesgo y puso 100 millones de
dólares sobre la mesa bajo las
siguientes condiciones cada fondo que
recaudará 12 millones de inversores
privados recibiría a cambio 8 millones
de inversión pública el gobierno se
quedaba con el 40 por ciento la
propiedad
en caso de que los proyectos tuviesen
éxito los inversores podían hacerse con
la participación del gobierno
simplemente devolviéndole la aportación
inicial más unos pocos intereses después
del éxito del dogma todo fue como una
bola de nieve más fondos vieron el éxito
y decidieron venir a israel y el fondo
que creamos captó más dinero sobre todo
empezó con 200 millones y en 10 años ya
habíamos conseguido traer 15.000 para
invertir en compañías locales investing
tullow que el campeón es es decir amigos
si las cosas iban bien el beneficio
recaiga fundamentalmente los inversores
y si las cosas marchaban mal el gobierno
compartía la pérdida esto puede parecer
injusto pero lo cierto es que la
inversión pública requerida era
relativamente pequeña y además el
gobierno esperaba recuperar cualquier
pérdida con los impuestos que genera
esta nueva industria desde entonces
prácticamente todos los programas
públicos en israel han seguido este
esquema y lo cierto es que los
resultados no pudieron ser mejores que
el dinero internacional comenzó a llegar
hubo financiación para prácticamente
cualquier idea y tan sólo los primeros
ocho años el número
con dos pasos de 20 a 513 el resultado
es que hoy israel tiene uno de los
mayores ecosistemas de capital
emprendedor del mundo y de acuerdo a los
últimos datos de la ocde la inversión
disponible para lanzar nuevas empresas
supera ojo los 150 dólares por persona y
año en españa por comparar esta cifra se
reduce a poco más de 35 dólares 40 veces
menos
la clave en todo este proceso es que los
fondos de capital-riesgo no sólo aportan
dinero también experiencia gestión y
contactos vitales
inmigración
israel es el país del mundo más abierto
a la inmigración uno de cada tres
ciudadanos a nación en el extranjero y
nueve de cada diez son bien inmigrantes
bien hijos o nietos de inmigrantes un
caudal de inmigración impresionante que
explica que su población haya pasado de
apenas 800 mil habitantes en 1948 cuando
se funda el país a más de 8 millones hoy
en día es decir en poco más de 60 años
se ha multiplicado por 10 en esta última
ronda de inmigrantes aproximadamente 50
judíos franceses llegaron al aeropuerto
de ben gurión en tel aviv de hecho
israel es la única nación de la historia
que recoge explícitamente en sus
documentos fundacionales la necesidad de
tener una política de inmigración
abierta así conforme a la ley de retorno
aprobada en 1950 y aún hoy en vigor todo
judío independientemente de donde haya
nacido tiene derecho a trasladarse
israel y este no es un factor baladí la
inmigración ha contribuido tanto al
milagro económico como cualquier otro
factor y es que a pesar de lo que dicen
muchos populistas las naciones más ricas
tienden a ser aquellas que tienen más
inmigrantes entre otros factores porque
éstos suelen tener tasas
vientos superiores a las de la población
local y porque además impulsan el
comercio internacional especialmente con
sus países de origen por cierto
próximamente le dedicaremos un vídeo a
esta cuestión
educación
la apuesta de israel por contar con un
sistema de educación de altísima calidad
forma parte casi de su identidad ya en
1918 30 años antes de la propia
fundación del estado de israel los
colonos judíos fundaron la universidad
hebrea de jerusalén y hoy el país cuenta
con una de las mayores tasas de
población con estudios universitarios
del mundo y sobre todo hay que decirlo-
ha hecho muy bien los deberes en cuanto
a la integración entre empresa y
universidad la financiación de las
universidades de israel a diferencia de
lo que ocurre por ejemplo en españa
depende en gran medida de los proyectos
financiados por empresas privadas con lo
que existen incentivos evidentes a
colaborar con ellas y además logran la
mayor ratio de creación de empresas de
toda la ocde transferencia de
conocimiento es imprescindible esto nos
está llevando al mundo universitario
realmente profesional a colaborar cada
vez de manera más estrecha y yo creo que
eso es muy bueno en israel las ideas se
transforman en empresas y en empleos
bien todos estos elementos junto a
factores culturales como la luz para la
tendencia a cuestionar todo que es clave
en la cultura judía el ejército y la
mide obligatoria que favorecen la
movilidad social poniendo en contacto
directo
de diferentes estratos sociales y
formaciones o la reforma de netanyahu en
2003 de las que ya hablaremos han
alimentado el éxito de israel un país
que desde 1980 ha más que duplicado su
población ha multiplicado por cuatro el
número de empleos y ha crecido a una
tasa media del 4% anual de tal forma que
hoy su pib per cápita con 36 mil dólares
es superior por ejemplo al de españa o
italia bueno tú qué opinas se
consolidará israel como la mayor
potencia tecnológica del mundo que es
replicable su modelo a otros países
espero que te haya resultado interesante
este vídeo ya sabes que podrás encontrar
muchos más en nuestro canal de youtube y
también en los próximos domingos en la
vanguardia.com un saludo y hasta la
próxima amigos